[Musik]
Tatort Deutschland die crime Doku von
Bild
4 juni 1960
der Bude minieri ist ein länglicher See
etwa drei Kilometer lang einen Kilometer
breit und ein beliebtes Ausflugsziel für
Angler und Erholungssuchende aus der nur
30 km entfernten Hauptstadt Helsinki am
späten Nachmittag halten zwei Motorräder
an der Südseite des Sees auf einem Sitz
der 18-Jährige Seppo anteo Boys Mann und
seine 15-jährige Freundin Anja toulicky
genannt
auf dem anderen seppos bester Freund der
ebenfalls 18-Jährige Nils Wilhelm
gustavson und seine Freundin Meiler
irmiund wie toliki ist auch sie gerade
15 Jahre alt die vier wollen Zelten und
das lange Pfingstwochenende am See
verbringen die Jungs haben eine
Angelausrüstung eingepackt Brot Wurst
zwei Flaschen Likör und ein paar Bier
besorgt
sie finden eine versteckte Lichtung
zwischen Birken und Kiefern auf seiner
kleinen Halbinsel die etwas abseits der
großen Badestellen und das Pfingst
Ausflugs Trubels liegt
nachdem sie ihren Platz gefunden und die
Sachen abgeladen haben fahren sie noch
mal los
den Jungs ist aufgefallen dass sie noch
Limonade brauchen sehr klar irgendwas
brauchen sie ja um den starken Likör zu
mixen auf dem Weg zum See hatten sie
einen Kiosk gesehen nur etwa einen
Kilometer die Straße hinunter kurz nach
sieben sind sie wieder bei ihren Zelten
naja ihrem Zelt sie haben nämlich nur
eins und das ist eigentlich nur für zwei
Personen gedacht aber gut ich schätze
mal zwei frisch verliebte Teenie Pärchen
die zum Zelten fahren da ist es nicht so
schlimm wenn es ein bisschen kuscheliger
wird das könnte man vermuten sie bauen
also auf und gehen baden der See ist
jetzt fast leer die meisten Baden bin
sind auf dem Rückweg nach Helsinki oder
bei ihren eigenen Zelten der Beginn
eines wunderbaren Wochenendes oder eines
Horrorfilms ihr kennt uns ihr ahnt auch
wie es wird es ist auf jeden Fall der
Beginn eines Horrorfilms
bei dem allerdings die entscheidenden
Stellen gelöscht sind und damit herzlich
Willkommen zu Tatort Deutschland und
einer echt finsteren und mysteriösen
Geschichte aus Finnland mein Name ist
Mirko Kasimir und ich bin Toni Heyer
damit jetzt genug gelabert Mirko erzähl
weiter am Sonntagmorgen es ist
Pfingstsonntag 1960 spazieren zwei
worldwatcher gegen 6 Uhr das Südufer des
bodumsees entlang als sie eine kleine
Halbinsel erreichen entdecken Sie zwei
Motorräder und ein zusammengeklapptes
Zelt jemand scheint auf dem Zelt zu
liegen er bewegt sich auf der Lichtung
sind auch Schnaps und Bierflaschen
verstreut offensichtlich hatte jemand
betrunken das Zelt ruiniert und schläft
nun seinen Rausch auf statt im Zelt aus
sie sehen einen zweiten älteren Mann in
einem hellen Hemd der die Lichtung
verlässt und im Wald verschwindet
vielleicht ein Freund oder der Vater des
Betrunkenen Jungen vielleicht hat er im
Wald dringende kleine oder große
Geschäfte zu erledigen
die beiden würden sich gern die
Motorräder näher ansehen aber sie wollen
niemanden stören also gehen sie weiter
etwa zur selben Zeit sitzt ein
14-jähriger Junge auf einem
Felsvorsprung und wartet auf sein Kumpel
die beiden wollen Angel die Sonne ist
bereits aufgegangen der See liegt ruhig
und still wie verlassen es ist quasi die
Ruhe vor dem Sturm bevor die ganzen
Ausflügler aus der Hauptstadt die
Badestellen stürmen
die Stille wird von knackenden Zweigen
unterbrochen als ein Mann aus dem Wald
hervorbricht ungefähr 80 Meter von den
jungen entfernt der Mann scheint in
seinen 20ern zu sein hat braunes Haar
und trägt helles Hemd und dunkle Hose er
hat es eilig der Junge schaut ihm nach
während er sich in südlicher Richtung
bewegt aber er vergisst ihn schnell
nachdem er außer sich geraten ist doch
er wird sich bald an ihn erinnern gegen
11 Uhr kommt ein Zimmermann an der
Lichtung vorbei und erkennt schnell dass
die Unordnung nicht die Folge eines
Trinkgelages ist und dass der junge Mann
auf dem Zelt keinen Rausch ausschläft
was er vor sich sieht lässt keinen
Zweifel daran mit was für eine
Geschichte wie es hier zu tun haben
der Junge auf dem Zelt ist Nils Wilhelm
Gustafsson sein Kiefer und das Jochbein
sind gebrochen die ganze linke
Gesichtshälfte zugeschwollen er hat
schwere Stichverletzungen im Gesicht und
am Unterarm aber er lebt als einziger
der vier Jugendlichen die tags zuvor zu
einem unbeschwerten Campingtrip
aufgebrochen sind
Emily Nils Freundin liegt neben dem Zelt
mehrere Schläge mit einem stumpfen
Gegenstand haben ihren Kopf zertrümmert
und müssen sie praktisch sofort getötet
haben doch der Mörder war noch nicht
fertig mit ihr ihre Hose ist
heruntergezogen die Bluse hochgeschoben
und 15 nach dem Tod hinzugefügte
Stichverletzungen deuten auf einen
wahren blutrauschen
und der Po findet die Polizei tot im
zusammengebrochenen und aufgeschlitzten
Zelt
der Täter muss die Leine des Zelts
gekauft haben und die im Inneren
Gefangenen und verwirrten Jugendlichen
durch die Zeltbahnen hindurch mit einem
stumpfen Gegenstand und einem Messer
angegriffen haben
tui-liki und Seppo starben offenbar so
fort während
irmeli und Nils ist nach draußen
schafften wo der Täter sie weiter
Angriff vielleicht wurde er dann von den
Vogel beobachten gestört und floh in den
Wald bevor er auch niest töten konnte
so reimt es sich zumindest die Polizei
zusammen und setzt ihre Hoffnung auf
Nils den einzigen Überlebenden der
bewusstlos in eine Klinik eingeliefert
wird am Donnerstag dem 9 juni erwacht
Nies Gustav seinem Krankenhaus
seine Mutter ist bei ihm das Sprechen
fällt ihm schwer wo er ist will er
wissen warum im Krankenhaus habe ich
einen Motorradunfall gehabt seine Mutter
schüttet zögern den Kopf schnell stellt
sich heraus dass Nils der einzige
Überlebende und wichtigste Zeuge keine
Erinnerung an die Tat hat aber er kann
den Tag davor beschreiben und erzählt
dass er und Seppo nachts gegen 3 Uhr
noch einmal aufgestanden und zum See
gegangen waren das deckt sich mit einem
nächtlichen Tagebucheintrag eines der
Mädchen
irgendwann seien sie zum Zelt
zurückgekehrt und wieder eingeschlafen
das Nächste woran er sich erinnert ist
das Aufwachen im Krankenhaus aber es
gibt viele Hinweise und Theorien denen
die Polizei in den nächsten Wochen
nachgehen wird
Toni ich denke wir sollten mal die
beiden Hauptverdächtigen vorstellen
schieß los Marco da ist zum einen Karl
Waldemar Güstrow der 51-Jährige betreibt
den Kiosk an dem Nils und Seppo am Abend
vor den Morgen Getränke gekauft haben er
gilt als extrem jähzornig und hasst die
Touristen von denen er mit seinem Kiosk
doch eigentlich ganz gut leben kann
mehrfach hat er bereits Leute
angegriffen die die Straße nutzten die
an seinem Haus vorbei führt auf einen
Lkw hat er mit seiner Schrotflinte
geschossen der Fahrer wurde von Scherben
im Gesicht getroffen
manchmal präparierte er die Straße mit
Brettern aus denen Nägel ragten und es
hieß er Verstecke Rasierklingen in den
Äpfel in seiner Bäume
aber was ihn wirklich verdächtig macht
sind drei besondere Angewohnheiten
güstroym hat immer eine Eisenstange im
Kofferraum seines Wagens trägt meist ein
Jagdmesse am Gürtel und ist dafür
bekannt die Halteseile der Zelte von
Campern am See durchzuschneiden
ah das klingt schon sehr verdächtig aber
ich glaube mein Verdächtiger der kann
damit halten am 6 juni 1960 also am
Pfingstmontag wird ein bewusstloser Mann
in ein Krankenhaus in Helsinki
eingeliefert sein Pullover war schmutzig
und mit roten Flecken übersät die selben
Flecken finden sich auch an seinen
Händen und unter seinen Fingernägeln
steckt Erde
der Mann heißt Hans Assmann lebt in der
Nähe von Helsinki und wurde in
Deutschland geboren seine Frau begleitet
ihn ins Krankenhaus und erklärt den
Ärzten er sei nach starken
Magenschmerzen plötzlich bewusstlos
zusammengebrochen
ein kurzer kitzeltest das Arzt das aber
der entlockt dem angeblich bewusstlosen
ein Kichern zur Rede gestellt warum er
etwas vortäusche zeigt er keine Reue und
fängt stattdessen an das
Krankenhauspersonal zu beschimpfen und
zu bedrohen
kurze Zeit später fällt auf wie er immer
wieder seine Hände reinigt beinahe
besessen scheint er davon selbst als die
roten Flecken längst verschwunden sind
in den folgenden Tagen wird sein
Verhalten immer merkwürdiger er erzählt
herum dass er im Zweiten Weltkrieg
Wächter in Auschwitz gewesen sei
1943 hätten ihn die Russen festgenommen
nach zwei Jahren Kriegsgefangenschaft
habe er schließlich die Seiten
gewechselt und sei seither beim KGB dem
russischen Geheimdienst also ich würde
mal sagen wenn auch nur eins von beiden
stimmt dann hätte er das wohl kaum herum
erzählt ja aber andererseits
andererseits ist die Wahrheit manchmal
die beste Tarnung ich meine das werden
andere auch denken oder der muss Spinnen
sonst würde der das nicht erzählen
aber egal ob Wahrheit oder Spinnerei er
treibt es noch weiter
nach einigen Tagen wird er entlassen
kommt jedoch immer wieder für
Behandlungen in das Krankenhaus einmal
zeigt er einem Arzt einen Artikel den
aus einer deutschen Zeitung
herausgerissen hat und in dem es um
ungelöste Verbrechen geht in anderen mal
sagt er zu einem Chirurgen mit Verweis
auf dessen Skalpell dass er selbst ja
auch gut mit einem Messer umgehen könnte
allerdings würden im Gegensatz zum
Doktor die Leute am anderen Ende des
Messers nie überleben die Leute im
Krankenhaus kommen jedenfalls bald zu
der Überzeugung es mit dem Mörder vom
Bodom sie zu tun zu haben
und dann wird auch noch ein Phantombild
des Täters veröffentlicht das eine
gewisse Ähnlichkeit mit Hans Assmann hat
und dieses Phantombild beruht nicht etwa
auf den Aussagen der Zeugen die einen
Mann vom Zelt weggehen sahen sondern auf
denen von Niels gustavson der sich doch
eigentlich an nichts erinnern kann
zumindest nicht bewusst ein Psychiater
der Uni Helsinki versucht durch Hypnose
Zugang zu den Verschütteten Erinnerungen
zu gewinnen und bei der dritten Sitzung
hat er Erfolg Nils beschreibt unter
Hypnose den Angreifer und aufgrund
dieser Beschreibung wird ein Phantombild
angefertigt ja und auf dem Glauben die
Mitarbeiter im Krankenhaus in Helsinki
ihren seltsamen und unheimlichen
Patienten zu entdecken aber um es kurz
zu machen nein er ist es vermutlich
nicht Hans Assmann hat ein Alibi die
roten Flecken waren Farbreste von seiner
Arbeit Hans Assmann ist unschuldig davon
ist zumindest die Polizei überzeugt bis
heute gibt es aber viele Menschen die
ihn für den wahren Täter halten naja die
Geschichte ist auch einfach zu gut
KGB-Agent auch wenn das alles ein
bisschen wirklich klingt aber na gut was
ist denn mit dem kiosk-besitzer er
bleibt sehr lange der Hauptverdächtige
trotz eines Alibis aber schließlich muss
die Polizei auch diese Akte schließen
aus Mangel an Beweisen oder auch nur
handfesten hinweisen
es gibt unmittelbar nach dem Mord und
auch noch Jahrzehnte später immer wieder
Hinweise aus der Bevölkerung dutzende
potenzielle Täter werden unter die Lupe
genommen einige Male glaubt man einen
dringend Verdächtigen gefunden zu haben
aber all diese Hinweise und Spuren
erweisen sich als Sackgasse die
bodenmorde werden zum Cold Case
und dann 2003 nehmen die Ermittlungen
wieder Fahrt auf im März 2004 wird ein
61-jähriger Verdächtiger ein Busfahrer
aus Helsinki verhaftet am 4 august 2005
45 Jahre nach der Tat beginnt der
Prozess in einem der spektakulärsten
Mordfälle der finnischen Geschichte der
Mann vor Gericht also der 61-Jährige
Busfahrer der war zur Tatzeit 18 Jahre
alt und junger Mann Rock n' Roll Fan
Motorradfahrer und frisch verliebt es
ist niemand anderes als der einzige
Überlebende des Massakers Nils gustavson
[Musik]
okay das müssen wir erklären in Finnland
verjährt Mord nicht genau wie in
Deutschland und in vielen anderen
Ländern ein ungelöster Mordfall wird
also nie endgültig zu den aktengelegt
2003 nutzte der leitende Ermittler die
Fortschritte in der DNA-Analyse um
einige der Spuren vom Tatort neu zu
untersuchen vor allem die Schuhe von
Nils Gustav von interessieren ihn die
wurden von den Ermittlern nach der Tat
ungefähr 500 m vom Zelt entfernt und gut
versteckt aufgefunden als die Ermittler
an Nils schon das Blut von allen drei
Mordopfern finden aber nicht einen
Tropfen von Nils da sind sie sich sicher
den Täter gefunden zu haben
folgendes hat sich ihrer Meinung nach
zugetragen Mirko Nils und Depot haben
getrunken viel getrunken die Mädchen
wollten nichts abhaben umso mehr blieb
für Sie als die vier im kleinen Zelt
dicht beieinander liegen beginnt Nils
seine Freundin
Irmi zu bedrängen er hat ein Kondom
mitgenommen und das will er nur noch
benutzen
Irmi weigert sich doch Nils lässt nicht
von ihr ab irgendwann müssen Seppe und
TUI liki Eingreifen sie verbannen den
betrunkenen und übergriffigen Nils aus
dem Zelt soll er an der frischen Luft
seinen Rausch ausschlafen doch Nils
schläft nicht
in den frühen Morgenstunden schneidet er
die zeltschnüre durch und beginnt mit
einem Stein auf die drei im Zelt
Gefangenen Jugendlichen einzuschlagen
sepo gelingt ist dem Angriffe einen
Tritt an den Kopf zu versetzen und ihm
damit den Kiefer zu brechen das stachelt
Nils nur weiter an jetzt sticht er mit
einem Messer auf das Zelt ein
Irmi das eigentliche Ziel seiner Wut
versucht herauszukriechen doch noch
bevor sie sich ganz befreien kann
zertrümmert er ihr mit dem Stein den
Kopf und sticht dann in rasender Wut auf
seine Freundin ein
als er wieder bei Sinnen ist sind seine
drei Freunde tot er selbst ist verletzt
sein Kiefer gebrochen und irgendwie hat
er sich zwei Stichverletzungen zugezogen
doch das spielt keine Rolle Nils macht
sich planvoll an die Arbeit er sammelt
alle Wert Gegenstände ein unter anderem
die Motorradschlüssel und vergräbt sie
entweder im Wald oder versenkt sie im
See weit weg vom Tatort wo kein Polizei
Taucher sie finden wird so würde es nach
einem Raubmord Aussehen denkt er und um
die Ermittler noch weiter zu verwirren
entkleidet er Emilys Leiche teilweise um
den Verdacht auch in Richtung einer
Sexualstraftat zu lenken dann versteckt
er seine eigenen Blut bespritzten Schuhe
weit entfernt unter einem Stein kehrt
zurück und legt sich auf das Zelt
mehrere Tage spielte das bewusstlose
Opfer das nur durch unglaubliches Glück
überlebt hat bevor er beschließt die
Augen wieder zu öffnen und ganz arglos
zu fragen ob er einen Motorradunfall
gehabt habe
was denkt er
bis auf die Sache mit der tagelang
vorgetäuschten Bewusstlosigkeit klingt
das doch ziemlich einleuchtend oder
die Verteidigung sieht das anders sie
präsentiert alternative Version dafür
wie das Blut auf die Schuhe und wie die
Schuhe an diese weit entfernte Stelle
geraten sein können
sie weiß darauf hin dass Nils Füße
sauber waren und keine Anzeichen eines
langen barfuß-marsches durch den Wald
vom Schuh versteckt zurück zum Zelt
zeigen
sie findet Schwachstellen in der
Argumentation der Anklage und erinnert
dass mehrere Zeugen einen Mann gesehen
haben der vom Tatort Flo außerdem sein
Nils Verletzungen viel zu schwerwiegend
für so einen planvoll ist und
anstrengendes Handeln nach der Tat
gewesen das Gericht schließt sich dieser
Ansicht an am 7 oktober 2005 wird Nils
gustavson von allen Anklagepunkten
freigesprochen und erhält eine hohe
Entschädigung für die durch die lange
Untersuchungshaft verursachten
seelischen Leiden
[Musik]
die Morde am bodermsee sind bis heute
nicht aufgeklärt oder doch wir müssen
noch einmal auf Karl Waldemar gülström
zurückkommen den fiesen Kioskbesitzer
1969 neun Jahre nach den Morgen gerät er
eines Tages betrunken mit einem Nachbarn
in Streit kurz darauf schlägt seine Wut
in Verzweiflung um und er schreit den
Nachbarn an kapierst du denn nicht dass
ich der Boden Mörder bin was soll ich
denn jetzt tun sein Nachbar bekommt es
mit der Angst zu tun und sagt wenn du
wirklich der Mörder bist dann geh runter
zum sehen als auf dich denn ansonsten
wirst du für den Rest deines Lebens in
einer kleinen Zelle schmoren wenige
Stunden später findet mein Leiche die in
den stillen Wasser des Bodensees treibt
und was denkt ihr wer weiß
was denkst du es scheint auf jeden Fall
für alle genannten Verdächtigen einen
entsprechendes Motiv zu geben und das
spielt bei den Ermittlungen ja eine sehr
wichtige Rolle aber aufgrund fehlender
eindeutiger Beweise sind die Vermutungen
bei der Täter sein könnte dann leider
nur Spekulation bei Nils gustavson würde
mich zum Beispiel interessieren ob er
später noch mal mit Gewalttaten
aufgefallen ist denn ich vermute ein
Mensch der in so jungen Jahren eine so
blutrünstige Tat begangen haben soll da
ist doch die Wahrscheinlichkeit ziemlich
hoch dass er in seinem späteren Leben
sicher mit ähnlichen Gewalt hatten
aufgefallen wäre oder
ja könntest du aber also schwierige
schwierige Kiste weil auf der einen
Seite könntest du solche Gewaltexzesse
auch mit
[Musik]
unterbewusst schwellendem Trauma für
argumentieren mich würde eher
interessieren ob er vielleicht doch noch
irgendwie Erinnerungen im Laufe der Zeit
zurückgewonnen hat also das finde ich
war wirklich interessant okay ihr habt
das einfach komplett ausgelöscht ist
kann ich mir irgendwie nicht vorstellen
darüber hinaus weiß man natürlich auch
nicht genau welche Spuren wie damals
gesichert wurden so dass man heute so
viele Jahre später natürlich auch nicht
mehr genau und nachvollziehen kann wie
sich der Tatort genau gestaltet hat
heute würde man da vielleicht noch mal
mit anderen Augen drauf sehen gut ist
dass man auf jeden Fall diverse dNA
Spuren sichern konnte aber auch die
haben ja nichts gebracht und vielleicht
ist der Täter ja auch eine Person die
überhaupt gar nicht dieses überhaupt gar
nicht in den
Personenkreis der Verdächtigen geschafft
hat ja vielleicht ist es halt
irgendjemand der halt noch nie irgendwo
da im Kreis der Verdächtigen drin war
das ein sehr guter Punkt also das war ja
ein sehr beliebter Badesee die werden
sicherlich auch nicht die einzigen
gewesen sein die dort gezählt haben
guter Punkt
offiziell ist der Fall aber auf jeden
Fall ungelöst Nils gustavson gilt als
entlastet und der Tod des Kioskmann ist
einfach als Selbstmord eines
Alkoholkranken launischen Kerls um es
mal so salopp zu sagen ja und vielleicht
werden auch aus diesem Grund die Morde
am Bodensee für immer ein Rätsel bleiben
für immer ein Cold Case und damit sind
wir am Ende unseres heutigen falls wir
haben die Geschichte der Bruder Morde
anhand einer ganzen Reihe von Quellen
nacherzählt die wichtigsten waren die
Episode Lake Bodom das australischen
Podcast Case File True Crime sowie
Beiträge auf Historik mystery.com
medium.com und history define.com
danke fürs zuhören und wenn es euch
gefallen hat dann bitte bitte bewertet
uns empfehlt uns weiter und seid vor
allem bald wieder mit dabei bei Tatort
Deutschland